well I waited a year to do it because so
many different shows asked me to do a
bit of stick with it and I waited and
finally the Academy Club said would you
do something with idina menzel to kind
of sew it all up and you know finish the
full circle and so I said yeah they sent
me the script night weeks in a little
bit to fit my personality and great
because when you get it in Ostia I mean
it must be so nerve-wracking going up on
that stage I mean you can't imagine how
they people there
well there wasn't that it was that it
was smell that frenetically and I had
rehearsed it with the actual name inside
a moment of like yeah be you what were
you know in terms of the acting passages
what does he think of Eddie redmayne's
before his amazing any very well
deserved
yeah more we all expected both of them
to get it because they were so well
deserved whether yeah I mean I I think
the the nominations are the wind and
then I think you fine-tune it with the
with the actual wind but it's a great
night for all the actors the faulty
light now I don't know I said last year
was great little boards are this year
many boxes get on the gold smoke - thank
you